guns akimbo we had a whole argument
about what a Kimbo means cuz he wanted
to do this whole thing and putting his
legs up but I'm like I'm looking on
Google right now it says put your hands
on your hips and I fought to make sure
he did it that way and yet I had no
issue with not pulling out a prop gun
but just using my heart says more about
me than John words means something I
love Daniel Radcliffe movies that are I
like I love the Harry Potter films but
you know when I see him and stuff like
horns Swiss Army Man I get really
excited for that in the fact that he's
in an action movie
I got me really excited saw this on the
trending page let's do this
[Music]
oh geez Oh Oh can I wanted vaj road
hell yeah Oh God
Harry
as you reload Edward gun hands that's
the name for that I love that trailer
pure adrenaline pulpy hyper a kinetic
actually I really did get a lot of
wanted vibes and I mean the plot is
different but there are similarities I
thought it I mean first off Daniel
Radcliffe and James McAvoy American
accent sound kind of similar to one
another average Joe with the narration a
bit of a cynical mindset it's thrusted
into this hyper stylized action world
and will probably be an ultimate badass
in the end and of course some visual
aesthetics as well but this idea of a
dude who's thrusted into this sick
internet game with guns nailed to his
hands v there's gonna be a lot of great
physical comedy to come from it the
action does look awesome that other girl
with the weird hair and the tats and
stuff the veil and girl Salinger look
yeah she that is that Samara weaving
from ready or not if you guys haven't
seen ready or not that is a really
really underrated movie from 2019 Samara
weaving is excellent in the film and
after seeing her in that and they seen
her do this and Lee has it so cool for a
Rhys Darby from yes man and also the
flight of the conchords own HBO there's
so much look forward to here I am yeah
this looks great this looks like a whole
bunch of grindhouse fun yeah this
reminded me of like a free guy or one of
those movies about like an app game that
goes too far but taken to like a
heavy-metal gonzo extent which is what
made it look super exciting like I'm
getting at vibes from other movies I
thought of upgrade to a little bit just
in some of the look and some of this
sort of like I'm in a hyper violent
situation but I'm also a little like
skeeved out by it and I think Daniel
Radcliffe yeah I love his little niche
that he's carving out with these
interestingly esoteric but also kind of
fun and quirky you know movies that have
like pulp but also just these
interesting like I'm curious to see what
the stew
blossoms out into because right now it's
pretty basic you know it's a revenge and
retrieval sort of a mission he's gonna
have to form an unlikely alliance with
some more weaving and stuff but he's
trying to save his ex-girlfriend right
yeah yeah yeah so like I'm curious to
see what will make the story itself
rollicking and original but yeah just
the look of everything I haven't seen
death gasm but I've heard a lot of good
things about that and I've heard that
that's a pretty wild movie this seems to
have a similar kinetic wild again heavy
metal energy
it's almost looks like a like a more
cyberpunk more objectively fun version
of like a Mandy almost you know with
like the crazy dudes with chainsaws and
like it's not just guns even it looks
like a murder party or something
well this director has a visual effects
artist background work on some major
major films I get excited for those
especially when they've proven that they
can actually direct cuz this is not some
huge studio film but the effects look
great because you got a director at the
helm who clearly knows how to make some
really great effects in camera and of
course imposed on computer or whatever
it's cool the C is sort of I don't know
if this would qualify as like
technically independent film cause it's
not like major studio produced but it's
cool to see one of these lower if I like
produced films but I also have this look
aesthetic appeal quality to it that does
feel like more grandiose I'm sure this
is gonna be really funny stuff I just
love a Daniel Radcliffe does not take
himself seriously like every interview
I've ever seen him in he seems like he
really does have this boyish sort of
insecure quality about him and it seems
like he has learned to really play to
those charming humorous strengths that
he does have it's like he can choose
whatever projects he wants now because
he's got unlimited money for the rest of
his life collecting checks so he can do
a lot of these interesting character are
journeys that are experimental I'm also
really happy to that this trailer seems
to be getting pretty popular for some
random film that no one has probably
really you've ever heard of unless they
really follow like Daniel Radcliffe news
because I saw it on the training page on
my
what the hell is this movie Daniel
Radcliffe is living the dream I mean you
do like a wildly popular franchise and
just go off and do whatever random indie
stuff you want to do like oh I'm jealous
I mean they're like vibes to it that
kind of you know seem a little bit like
an Edgar Wright film especially more of
his crazier films like Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world or something like that
the world that called skim some schism
schism the world of schism does weird
internet kind of like this it sounds a
bit like the Running Man that concept
but a lot more global and random it's
like the updated dark web version just
like everybody tunes in do you know
which they should make a running man
remake like it'd be a pretty relevant
right now and they could really update
anything zombie did it it's called 31 oh
yeah curious to see how much of that
world and what the rules are of that
because right now it just kind of seems
like you equip people you watch them go
Unleashed and go crazy but I want to see
if like are there any rules to this
world at all or do they have some kind
of omnipresence where they can alter or
adjust your moves to the arc of whatever
story because I think it's supposed to
be the like the some are weaving
characters like the lead figure on
schism so maybe I don't know if they'll
have like you know rules about what you
can do to other people or whatever
tonally already this is not a red band
trailer but totally you can't let you
feel how violent this movie is going to
be because it's gonna only imagine with
a red band trailer just how insanely
violent and gory this film was gonna be
and you know that just makes for a
rollicking good time and I vote there's
gonna be some great hilarious stakes
primarily in the first half of act 2
when he wakes up with the guns like that
bit when he's going to the police
city like he can't ask for help he can't
drive a car he doesn't know it just
looks like a threat everywhere he goes
it looks like he's just wielding guns
it's gonna be the wackiest
fish-out-of-water coming yeah for like
20 good minutes that's I mean but Dan
Radcliffe is great in this kind of genre
I think for this kind of character which
is so different from like it's one it's
weird to be like I wish people would not
just only think of Harry Potter when
they go to Daniel Radcliffe yet I keep
bringing up how he's different than
Harry Potter so automatically I'm
linking him to Harry Potter
let's do it now that he's done with
Harry Potter something so different and
yeah I feel like I think it's the
conversation every time so let's take
bets about how long it'll take for that
stuff does not bring that up yeah when
is he gonna age to the point where he
doesn't look like Daniel Radcliffe's it
looks awesome I'm really excited about
it guys would you think of this trailer
and you want Daniel Radcliffe to do more
films like this have you seen ready or
not what do you think of Samarra we've
in common but lovely subscribe click
notification bells you could check us
out on patreon where we do weekly Q&A TV
show reaction stream along with many of
those shows have reaction highlights
included that we edit ourselves he does
music video reactions weekly last one
well at least let's give a pitch from
the day shout-out to a beautiful man
from James no briga James sincerely
wanted to thank you for showing your
support he sent me over a link as I saw
his I'm nail that he's rocking a guitar
so he's really into music sent me over a
song that him and his wife Katie wrote
and performed together
it's called changing names scars I
actually listened to the whole thing I
thought it was a really beautiful song
he's great at guitar his wife has a
beautiful voice it's a great song
there's a link in the description box to
go check this out thank you so much and
please continue to be a rollicking
artist hopefully I stick around our
patreon page a little bit longer just a
little bit don't want you to stay too
long never know some people get to know
us too well don't don't like a lot of
times yeah I like ooh what did I see in
you so before we get outed in the public
sphere we outstay our welcome you know
you might want to consider writing a
song too two more months stay increase
your public